[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello, my
name is Dustin Kirkland,
I'm a product manager
at Google, and I'm
joined by two of my colleagues:
Andrew Jackson, a software
engineer at Google,
and Josh Hoke, also
a software engineer at Google.
They are going to tell us about
a pretty exciting model being
trained on top of Kubernetes.
And they're currently training
another Go AI; an AI that's
learning to play the game Go.
All right, give us a little
bit about this project,
and how it got started.
ANDREW JACKSON: Sure, OK.
So, DeepMind is a
different Alphabet company
based in London,
and they're mostly
a research-focused company
that wrote this paper that
was published in
Nature about mastering
the game of Go using tree-search
and deep neural networks.
And this was sort
of a revelation,
because beating
professional Go players has
been a longstanding goal
in artificial intelligence.
It has been a long time in
coming, whereas Deep Blue was,
what, 30 years ago?
Was it 30 years ago?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Close to, 90s, yeah.
ANDREW JACKSON: Long time, yeah.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW JACKSON:
20, 30 years ago?
Go has seemed a
really long way away.
And then out of nowhere,
DeepMind's like,
"oh, by the way, we did that."
And they published
this paper, and it
was kind of a revelation.
And then later the
next year, I think
they played world champion
Lee Sedal in Seoul.
They published
another paper where
they said that they didn't
just train a network
to beat a professional
Go player,
they actually trained it with
no human input whatsoever;
that it started from
essentially random noise,
and learned how
to play by itself.
JOSH HOKE: And what was crazy
is that this Go AI was better.
ANDREW JACKSON: It was
better than the first one.
JOSH HOKE: It was
better, it was fantastic.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
That's fantastic.
OK, so that's the DeepMind team.
Now, this is a different
group at Google
that you're representing here.
ANDREW JACKSON: We're actually
not a group at Google at all.
So this is not a
group at Google,
and this is a side project.
This is an enthusiast
project, because--
JOSH HOKE: 20% project.
ANDREW JACKSON: We're Go
players who love the game Go,
and we really wanted to have a
chance to play against AlphaGo.
But of course we couldn't, so
we had to sort of rewrite it.
And so Minigo is an
open source, ground-up
rewrite- I shouldn't
even call it a rewrite-
it's a implementation based
on their published work.
It shares no code, we're not
related to that team at all.
We have no relationship
with that team
whatsoever, other than
the fact that we're
able to implement
their published papers
and try and reproduce
their results.
So this is sort of Interesting
from a reproducibility
of results perspective, and
also that this is an open source
demonstration.
They had built a really
fast performance solution
that was really baked into the
Google stuff, as we assume.
And so what we
wanted to do was, we
wanted to provide an excellent
example of how you could
use the Google Cloud
platform, and really amplify
and leverage some very
limited developer resources
to try and achieve some
really amazing results.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK so, this
is an open source project
built on your 20%
time at Google,
our Friday afternoons where we
can work on fun things related
to the field.
Now tie this to KubeCon, we
here at KubeCon in Copenhagen,
and you guys just gave a talk?
JOSH HOKE: Absolutely.
So, we just gave a talk, because
the whole way that we trained,
the whole way we got
data, was with Kubernetes.
We had this problem
where we needed
to create hundreds, thousands,
actually millions of games
in order to get the
sort of strong model.
So what did we do?
We used Kubernetes.
We used machine learning.
ANDREW JACKSON: So what
did we do with her?
JOSH HOKE: Machine
learning, that's right.
ANDREW JACKSON:
Machine learning.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK, so--
ANDREW JACKSON: It's
kind of a punch line,
but I think the
important part here
is that this is
reinforcement learning, where
the algorithm has to create
its own data to train on.
And that creation of data
is a really expensive part
of the overall process.
So, in other reinforcement
learning applications
like robotics, running
these simulations
that produce the next
iteration of data
is really computationally
expensive,
whereas for the Go domain-
for the domain of playing Go-
that can be very
easily parrallelized
in a very natural way.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So the
parallelization- now,
you guys ran a huge model to
train your implementation-
and you used Kubernetes
to orchestrate
the playing of the games.
Is that right, more or less?
JOSH HOKE: That's right.
So we use Kubernetes-
we actually use GKE-
and we created a
giant, giant cluster.
And not only--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Define giant.
JOSH HOKE: I think
we were running, what
do you say, like 2000 nodes?
ANDREW JACKSON: 2,000 GPUs.
JOSH HOKE: Right so, yeah--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: GPU instances?
JOSH HOKE: Right.
So not only were we using
a whole bunch of machines,
we were using a whole bunch
of GPUs to train our models.
ANDREW JACKSON: Right.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And this problem
is particularly well suited
for CUDA and GPUs, right?
JOSH HOKE: Absolutely.
And so, the reason why
it's suited to GPUs
is because we're running
things through machine learning
models, through neural networks.
It's just math- just matrices-
and the thing that GPUs
are really good at is
actually running things
through matrices.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
OK, so each game
that was simulated-
some 20,000 games that
were simulated- each of
those ran in a Kubernetes pod
as a container?
JOSH HOKE: That's right.
And we scheduled out
all these pods, all
with the communities
batch API, the job API,
and we set the
parallelism way up,
and Kubernetes just
took care of scheduling
on all these machines.
It was fantastic.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Now can
I docker pull this image
and, I don't know, run a
game simulation for fun
on my laptop, obviously
not GPU accelerated?
ANDREW JACKSON: Absolutely.
If you have the GPU
accelerated version
you can do that as well.
That will be a different
image, but for sure, we
have these available.
You can pull down the image.
We actually have a UI
attached to that image,
so you can actually
watch it play, and see
it think as you do that.
That's actually our
demo that we have.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: I'd
love to see that.
So how long does playing
a game take a simulation?
ANDREW JACKSON: Just
a couple of minutes.
JOSH HOKE: Just
a couple minutes.
If you don't have a GPU, it
can take quite a long time.
ANDREW JACKSON: But it depends
how much you want it to think.
JOSH HOKE: That's right.
ANDREW JACKSON: That's
the real question.
You want it to think a
while, it could be done.
You want it to
think a long time,
it would take a long time.
You want it to think very
quickly, won't take as long.
It's your choice.
JOSH HOKE: But with GPUs, maybe
a couple of minutes for a game.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Couple
of minutes a game.
ANDREW JACKSON:
Almost all of the load
is taken care of
by the GPU, there's
very little work that's
actually done by the processor
if you're using
GPU acceleration.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: All
right, fantastic.
I would love to see your demo.
ANDREW JACKSON: You got it.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Talk us through this.
ANDREW JACKSON: All right,
so what we're seeing here
is we are seeing- well, what
we'll see in a few seconds,
I guess I should wait.
What we're seeing here is we're
going to see Minigo think.
It's going to be
trying to figure out
what moves will be played.
So on the left side, we see
the principal variation,
and it just decided that
it wants to play this move.
So now it's going to be my
turn, I'm gonna play there,
and then we're going to
see Minigo think again.
So I decided to play there,
and Minigo is thinking,
white will play one then
black will play two,
then white will play three.
And as those
numbers move around,
it's changing its
mind about what
it thinks is the best
outcome for both sides.
The other graphs
that we see here,
so this board up
here at the top is
the actual inferences that
are happening on the model
right now.
So each of those is 1/20 of the
total number of possible board
positions that it's looking at.
So just like how a human
would play the game when
we try to think ahead
and anticipate what's
going to happen, and then, by
visualizing what will happen,
we then try and
decide whether or not
we like where we're going.
Minigo is doing
exactly the same thing.
It's trying to read ahead
what the best choices are
for either person,
and essentially
figure out whether it likes
where the game is developing.
So that's what the
top one is, that's
each of those inferences.
The middle one is all
of the different moves
that it's exploring.
The bottom one is the change in
score for the given play-out.
This graph that you see in
the upper right-hand corner
is how it thinks the game
is going for each side.
As it goes up, it
thinks one side
is winning, as
it's going down, it
thinks the other
side is winning.
And so, all of that de-bug
information is all there.
JOSH HOKE: Yet I should
say, one of the key things
is, of course Minigo things
much faster than we do.
And that's why we're
only sampling 1/20.
ANDREW JACKSON:
We're only sampling
1/20 of its table positions.
JOSH HOKE: Its
positions, that's right.
ANDREW JACKSON:
So, as Go players,
this is really
interesting for us
to watch and see what it's
thinking of when it sees things
that we maybe don't
think of, or moves
that we wouldn't think of.
And we can also see what it
thinks the continuation is,
what will happen after that.
So this is a really great study
tool, and it's useful for us
as Go players.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And I should say,
one thing that's
super fascinating
is, I look at this
game and I'm like,
this is something
that I would play.
This actually looks like
a very human game to me.
JOSH HOKE: That's right.
This is a smaller model,
we should mention.
This is a nine-by-nine
game of Go.
The real game of Go is actually
four times as big as this,
but this is a smaller
version that is easier for us
to run locally, and essentially
give a demo on a laptop
instead of on a big
beefy GPU machine.
So this is a smaller version,
it's a smaller model as well.
But as a result, that
doesn't really matter.
We've got full sized
models as well,
you can download those
also off of our bucket
with all of our data.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Are you
ready to take on a human?
ANDREW JACKSON: Yeah,
we've taken on humans.
This has been playing in
public against anybody who
wants to play it on Go servers.
It's still in
development, and we're
hoping that we can
replicate the results,
and then also start to
explore what else can be done
with it, what can be added,
what other sorts of options
there are.
JOSH HOKE: But there's
definitely a lot to improve.
ANDREW JACKSON: A lot to do.
JOSH HOKE: There's always
bugs to figure out,
we're always making it better.
ANDREW JACKSON: If
you want to find us,
this is all on GitHub,
right under the TensorFlow
repository.
So github.com/tensorflow/minigo,
we'll take any sort of pull
requests, comments,
issues, complaints,
conspiracy theories,
whole thing.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: What a
fascinating, fascinating
project.
Just tying this back to
Kubernetes one last bit.
So, Kubernetes provided you
some infrastructure underneath.
Without a Kubernetes,
What were your options, I guess?
ANDREW JACKSON: So,
after I had finished
the initial
implementation of this,
I realized that the hard part
wasn't actually implementing
the neural network.
The hard part was
figuring out how
to do this huge amount of
self-play and create the data.
It's not just 20,000 games,
it's 20,000 games per model,
and you need to do
500 models, maybe.
So it's a huge amount
of this compute
that I needed to
figure out how was I
going to do that when each
game takes minutes to play.
And luckily I knew a guy
who worked on Kubernetes,
and I was able to say, hey
Josh, how should I do this?
Should I like, script a bunch
of bash to manage VMs directly?
JOSH HOKE: Totally.
Bash is the right option.
ANDREW JACKSON: Oh man,
I had all of these other,
like, how am I going
to get this at scale
with only the open source tools?
Because I didn't have any
of the Google infrastructure
to lean on.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: I guess
that's the other piece, right,
the infrastructure.
You didn't have to
provision a single VM,
you didn't have to find a GPU.
ANDREW JACKSON: I did
have to do a lot of work
in getting the code to
work inside a docker image,
because this involved
making those docker
images is very performant.
Like, Docker's
abstraction is, well,
don't worry about what the
actual silicon is underneath.
But TensorFlow and
GPUs were very much
trying to compile with all of
the processor optimizations,
we're trying to compile with
the latest NVIDIA drivers.
Getting all of that to work
inside the docker image
was non-trivial, but it's
also gotten a lot easier.
I think in particular
with the launch of GPUs
on GKE, that whole situation
with getting the latest
drivers, getting
CUDA DNN installed,
that's all come a long way.
And even when we started
this, it was only,
I guess six months ago.
It's come a long
way, just since then.
So it's pretty exciting--
JOSH HOKE: Super exciting.
ANDREW JACKSON: To see
that sort of progress.
But that hard part was
getting that performance
inside those containers.
So it is interesting to
see that the containers are
no barrier to this sort of
high performance computing.
If you want to use GPUs
and go as fast as you can,
you want to use all of
the extended processor
instructions, you can do
that too in your instances
with is a little bit of
care in how you craft them.
So I think that's a
pretty interesting.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
That's fantastic.
Josh, Andrew, thank
you for your time.
JOSH HOKE: Thank you.
ANDREW JACKSON: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]